- Today is Saturday, huh?
- [Mark] You what?
- Today is Saturday, right?
- [Mark] Today's Saturday, yeah.
- I didn't realize today
was Saturday the 15th.
I think this is the first time
I've seen you down here on a Saturday.
- [Mark] It's a Saturday.
All right, so, Jerry.
- [Jerry] Yes.
- [Mark] So, we had a
whole bunch of setbacks
with your apartment.
The painting, and the
getting it furnished,
and new clothes, and all that.
We had COVID, we had the
rioting that happened downtown.
Then, Gary in your
building, who worked there,
passed away from COVID.
- Yeah.
It's been nothing, but-
So, all the GoFundMe
money that we generated
for you has just been sitting there.
I've been paying your
rent, which is great,
but that's pretty much
all we were able to do
for a long time.
But, you got new clothes you got new bed,
towels, kitchen stuff, new apartment.
All painted up.
Everything's all nice and new.
- [Jerry] Yes, I appreciate
that, Mark, very much.
- [Mark] So, what's the nicest thing about
having an apartment rather than
living on the street, as you were?
When I first met you.
- [Jerry] Well, you get a lot of rest,
you clean yourself up,
and
you stay warm in the
winter time. It's great!
It's really good.
- [Mark] A place to hang out.
- On the streets, I
was getting sick a lot.
- [Mark] You would get sick a lot?
- On the streets, yeah.
If it's cold, yeah.
I feel more safer.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Being on the streets,
you're not really asleep.
You might get a time where
you you're not really asleep,
because you never know who's around.
You know, people walking around all over.
It's great to be inside.
It's all thanks to you, Mark.
Yes, definitely. Yeah.
- [Mark] Well, you've become like a
mini celebrity now because of your video.
- Yes, a lot of people.
- [Mark] People recognize you.
- Yeah, people, yeah. I've
seen your video, yeah.
- [Mark] Do people come up
to you all the time and-
- Yeah, they tell me about it. Yeah
- [Mark] Say nice things
to you, rather than-
- Yeah, they mention your name too.
And they know I'm inside
this place here too.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- They know I'll be inside
this place, taking a video.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- Yeah, 'cause they seen it before.
They ask, "Where's that place you was in?"
I say, "That's our Studio."
Yeah, they asked about it.
They asked about this.
Yeah. You been inside. Yeah.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Well, it's nice that
people now know your story.
- Yep, yep.
- [Mark] Because I think
a lot of people were
just frightened by you or whatever.
- Right, right. Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] Now they know the
backstory and it's like-
- A lot of people come to me.
I didn't know about you, about, you know,
what happened or anything like that.
They think I'm-
They treat me sometimes like
I'm being on the streets,
Yeah.
- [Mark] So, I've come to
see you many, many times now.
Probably a hundred times I've come over
and your mood is so consistent.
Every single time I see you,
you're in a great mood,
just as you are now.
You're personable, you're pleasant.
And you never get down from your situation
or what happened to you?
- [Jerry] Don't worry
about things in life.
You know where I get that from?
- [Mark] Where's that?
- [Jerry] That's in the Bible.
It says don't worry about things in life.
And you say, "How come?".
I say,
"I can't change this."
I can go into a shell if I want to.
I can really go in a shell.
You know what I'm saying?
Use it as an excuse, but I can't do that.
- [Mark] Do you ever feel like a victim?
- [Jerry] No, not really.
- [Mark] So many people
I talk to are always
are telling these victim stories.
They're victims, they're victims.
- [Jerry] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] And I never hear that from you.
- [Jerry] A lot of people
know what happened to me.
They know more about me than I do.
There's rumors out there that
I broke into a house
while people was there.
And shot me in my face.
(Jerry laughs)
I always hear stories down here.
Everybody knows things about me.
More than I do.
But like I said,
I gotta keep moving on.
I can't let this bring me way down.
And thank God.
I'd lose my mind.
A lot of people probably
couldn't take this.
A lot of guys out there,
they don't like me.
For one thing, Mark, is this here,
They seen this, right here.
I don't know nothin'.
And then,
they talk to me and find out
I'm not what they thought I was.
Damn you.
They say, "Damn you!"
They're mad. They thought
I'd be like this here.
I was born like this,
I don't know nothin',
I'm dumb or whatever.
I'm out on the streets.
And then, when they get talking to me,
or anything like that,
and I say, "Yes."
They don't like that.
- [Mark] Right. My
favorite thing about you,
is you seem to carry no anger.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] You don't seem
like an angry person at all.
- And they get mad.
- [Mark] Do you? Or about the
person that did this to you?
I mean, I think your views on forgiveness
are similar to mine.
In that,
you forgive for your,
you're doing it for yourself.
Not for the other person.
- Right.
- [Mark] By forgiving the other person,
you're more at peace.
- I can't live life like that.
I've got to keep on livin', Mark.
I'd go in a shell.
I can't do that though.
I love life.
Life is great, man.
Definitely.
- [Mark] I think your positive attitude-
- Yes, definitely.
- [Mark] Is like a motivational
speech, just in itself.
So, I mean, were you as
positive a person before
you're shooting?
- Yeah, definitely, yeah.
- [Mark] You were always positive?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Even when you were a younger man?
- I love livin'.
I love livin'.
I couldn't wait for morning time to come.
I would get up early in the morning.
And see the morning light.
- [Mark] And you had a lot of friends?
- Not too many.
I like to be by myself a lot,
sometimes, most of the time, yeah.
- [Mark] You're by yourself a lot now.
- Yeah, right now.
Like in that room there,
I sit back and listen to
that radio you bought me.
Yeah.
I don't do a whole lot.
I just sit in that room,
day in and day out.
Nothin'.
And then, plus, I got sick and stuff.
I can't go out.
I left my thing on the
thing too, at the house.
That spray thing, Mark.
I gotta have that with me.
- [Mark] For your, you
have a problem breathing.
- Yeah, I left it at my place, too.
Like, for example,
say that I didn't have
any more of the stuff.
I couldn't come outside for two weeks.
- [Mark] Without your medicine?
- Yeah, without my medicine, yeah.
I can't come outside two weeks.
I'll give you a good example.
To walk over here,
say I did not have the stuff.
To walk over here, I could walk over here
maybe in about 20 minutes.
- [Mark] That's like three or four blocks.
- Yeah.
Now that I have this
stuff, to walk over here,
it takes 20 hours.
It would never take twenty hours,
but I'm just giving you an example.
It take a while.
- [Mark] Yeah, it'd take a long time.
- I'd sit here and have to stop.
One time, I was by the flower shop,
where I panhandled, it was
where I first met you at.
I was like, "Uh-oh."
I didn't have my stuff on me.
And so, I was trying to
figure which would be better.
To get to a place and call 911.
Or go, right next to the parking lot,
at the corner there,
there's the fire station.
You know it's right there.
I walk over there. Which will be best?
Now, I'm down where I
used to be sitting at.
- [Mark] It's only two blocks.
- And I was thinking
about going to my place,
and then calling them.
But I couldn't do it.
When I got to the corner,
at the fire station,
the button you push is right there.
When I got there, I had to bend over
and catch my breath when I get to it.
When I to it, I looked at it.
I looked down and then looked at it.
I was so tired, I pushed it.
The guys came out
and gave me a breathing tube
right outside, out there.
At the fire, it's down this way, yeah.
At the fire department right there.
- [Mark] It's right there.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So, Jerry, what
advice would you give
to somebody who's
struggling with depression
or struggling with life?
Just having a hard time with life.
And you seem to be so content and happy.
- I'd just tell them
put their trust in God, in Jesus.
Keep their faith in Jesus.
He'll provide you a way,
if you provide him a way.
He'll provide they way.
- [Mark] Lots of guidance there, right?
- Yeah.
- Like I said, don't worry
about the things in life.
All you gotta do is believe in him.
He'll provide a way.
Like I said,
take my case.
Don't worry about the
things you can't change.
Just accept it.
That's what the Bible says.
Don't worry about the
things you cannot change.
Accept the things you can change.
- Yeah, yeah. Life is
beautiful, Mark. Yeah.
Hey, you think Biden is gonna win?
- [Mark] What's that?
- You think, put it this way,
do you think Trump gonna get reelected?
- [Mark] I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't even want to think about it.
I stay out of that stuff.
- [Jerry] I just go with the flow.
- [Mark] Yeah, you do.
- [Jerry] Yeah, I just go with the flow.
Because
they say politicians is crooks.
- [Mark] All right, Jerry.
Well, thank you for talk to me again.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] And I'm happy to help you out
with a new place to live.
- Oh, I appreciate that
Mark. Thank Mark, everybody.
- [Mark] And thank you to all the people
that donated to you.
- Yeah, thanks to people
that donated. Thank, Mark.
- [Mark] A lot of people
donated a lot of money to you.
- Yes.
Thank you, Mark and thanks, people.
And let me say, thank
Mark, everybody, too.
- [Mark] All right, thanks, Jerry.